ce que je souhaite c'est un véritable
plan pour la famille en trajectoire je
l'appelle un family act à la française
à l'instar de ce que font nos voisins
allemands ou italiens qui n'hésitent pas
à investir 22 milliards dans la famille
c'est dire à quel point ils ont mesuré
l'importance de ce virage à prendre pour
une politique familiale renforcer
véritable outil économique puissant de
relance de notre pays
là où je pense qu'un statu quo au
contraire ne ferait que rajouter de la
crise à la crise pour moi le principal
défi il est démographique depuis une
dizaine d'années on dénombre moins 100
mille naissances en france et 1,87
enfants par femme
donc on voit bien là l'enjeu de la
natalité est particulièrement importante
puisque la natalité la condition de
financement de notre modèle de
solidarité
je plaide pour une universalité pleine
et entière alors qu'est ce que ça
signifie d'abord supprimer la condition
de ressources pour attribuer les
allocations familiales ensuite verser
les allocations familiales dès le
premier enfant et supprimer le rang de
l'enfant dans la famille enfin regardez
la famille dans son ensemble à tous les
âges de la vie de la petite enfance
jusqu'à la dépendance bien objectif je
viens d'en parler c'est de relancer la
natalité
le deuxième objectif c'est de redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux français et là je
vais vous citer un exemple très concret
après les deux coups de rabot successifs
qui ont été portées au quotient familial
les familles de la classe intermédiaire
en vue leurs impôts augmenter de près de
790 euros par an en moyenne
le troisième objectif concerne la
conciliation entre la vie familiale et
la vie professionnelle
et là je propose de mettre en place un
service public de la petite enfance afin
de garantir à tous les parents un mode
de garde pour leurs enfants de 0 à 3 ans
avec une attention particulière portée
sur les familles monoparentales
[Musique]
où